great interest in languages
although when i was 17 as an anglophone
growing up in montreal i essentially
just spoke english even though we had
french at school and i think that's
quite typical
obviously we had french i had friends
from the age of whatever grade two grade
three and i did quite well in french and
school but i couldn't speak it
and then i happened to go to mcgill i
had a professor who
completely turned me on to french
civilization french culture blah blah
blah and then if you're living in
montreal and you want to learn french
it's not that difficult to do
so that was kind of my epiphany
i subsequently went to france for three
years which helped me improve my french
obviously
then i joined the federal government i
was sent to hong kong to learn chinese
so in hong kong they don't speak
mandarin but i learned mandarin in hong
kong so you don't necessarily have to be
in the environment where the language is
spoken
uh subsequently i went to japan where i
learned japanese there i was in the
environment where the language is spoken
then over the years i sometimes did a
bit with languages sometimes didn't i
had lots of books and stuff at home and
i always felt that the
different ways that were available to
learn languages or improve in languages
weren't very good
and so in night probably seven years ago
six years ago a number of things made me
interested once again in the subject of
how to subject to how to learn languages
a couple of things that really sort of
were
important to me
one was in those days the many this
player and then subsequently the mp3
player
the ability to have a very small device
a very portable device with very high
quality sound that you could always have
with you
because i as when i was learning chinese
i had a great big open reel
uh you know tape recorder so now it's
possible to have
the language with you all the time
and the second thing was the online
dictionary because all the time i was
learning language my major motivation
was content i could never understand the
grammatical explanations i wasn't
motivated to understand them i couldn't
remember them i couldn't use them
they were irrelevant to me so if i read
a book if i was doing chinese or
japanese i would just flip the pages
with the grammar all i wanted was
content and a word list
but now with an online dictionary such
as babylon you can take any content and
you can start learning it so if you
combine sound
with text where you have instant access
to dictionaries you have to meet a
tremendous the beginnings of a
tremendous language learning environment
so that was kind of the beginning of the
development of the system that we use
uh so
you know a couple of other comments to
me
language learning is what i call it's
all about me
motivation and efficiency
unfortunately in our school system we
have typically an unmotivated learner
and an inefficient
learning system and the results are not
very good
so i've read recently that in the
brunswick for example the the anglophone
school system has 12 years of 30 minutes
a day and at the end of 12 years they
found that the number of students who
could speak french at an intermediate
level
was 0.68
so they might just as well not have done
it because if they didn't do any french
they would probably have at least 0.68
percent whose father or mother with
francophone or who was on a visit or
something so in other words and that's
perhaps an extreme example but it is in
a bilingual province in canada it is the
reality
and i feel it's the same with a lot of
our esl instruction a lot of the
language and politically motivated
language instruction in canada is just a
colossal waste of money because
motivation and efficiency
are rarely there
have i reached my five minutes there
okay 30 seconds 30 seconds so
you know i've been listening recently
because i've been learning portuguese
portuguese and i've been listening to a
brazilian educator
ruben alves does anyone here speak
portuguese
okay you have to listen to ruben he is
phenomenal but he talks about teaching
as the art of creating hunger
and he there's a lot of stuff then that
flows from that
and he is uh at any rate i believe in
that as a as a teacher the the teacher
that i had back in night whenever was i
can't remember her 40 years ago who
turned me on he created hunger
for french once you've created the
hunger the person will start flying
they'll go for it so the key is to
create the hunger unfortunately the way
in which we teach languages
often discourages turns off the hunger
so i won't get into the link right now
because i'll i'll talk about that later
on some of the some of the other things
that i i feel about language learning is
the importance of content the importance
of taking it in before you even worry
about using it in other words i've been
learning russian
i don't hardly ever speak it but i can
speak it but i can listen to tolstoy
audio books i can read
but i do it on my own passively and you
needn't speak till you want to speak
and there should be no pressure on
people to speak or perform until they
want to
and the more you do the sort of passive
listening and reading the more you're
building up your vocabulary you're
building up your capability so that when
you want to or when you need to you'll
be in you're more likely to succeed
so that's another thing and i'll leave
it at that because there's a whole bunch
of other stuff i will have to say and
i'll
turn the floor over thank you
thank you very much steve for uh
a nice icebreaking session okay
hi there once again i'm robin matthew
and i'm an author of language logic and
it's great to be in vancouver which is
my hometown but also i just finished a
two-month book tour across canada so
it's nice to finish it up right here in
sofia books so
what really motivated me to write this
book was i wanted to give
students
adults basically the books for
adolescents and adults trying to learn
another language and i want to give them
a tool set of their own so what most
people don't know
is that adults can actually learn
foreign languages more quickly than
children
and that a lot of people are like oh
really is that true and i'm going to
tell you why because this is important
because if you're learning a language
there is a difference between how
children learn languages and how adults
learn languages and so if you if you
don't know that starting off then it's
going to make it a little bit harder for
you to get going so i'm going to tell
you about it to give you some
information
so basically children benefit from
something called mother ease and so it's
how adults speak to children so they use
a simplified grammar
and a limited vocabulary so they get the
foothold in the language they need but
also the repetition that they need to
then build upon those skills so they're
learning their first language as they're
learning their second language
okay
adults on the other hand you look like
adults
you act like adults for the most part
right and people want to speak to you
like an adult so when you're learning
another language you're entering at a
higher level so what that means is the
language you're encountering is going to
be more complex in terms of the sentence
structure
and you're going to be encountering more
vocabulary so you're not necessarily
going to be getting the repetition out
of those language interactions that you
would as a child and so what i wanted to
do with the book is really to put the
language learner in control of their own
language learning situation and
concentrate on the two main skills which
is
i hate to say grammar because it's kind
of a stigmatized word
it doesn't have to grammar is an
umbrella term for different things so
like punctuation spelling syntax
conjugation all those kind of things but
what i really want to focus on is syntax
and that's word order structure how the
how the words are combined together so
there's syntax and there's vocabulary
and syntax and vocabulary those two run
through all the four other main skills
so reading writing listening and
speaking so what i wanted to do with
this book was to give people language
learners
like a smartest board full of different
things they could do in order to
approach language learning to be more
successful
so it's what you don't know that holds
you back and so the longer people
struggle
the less desire they have to learn so
what i want to do is remove someone's
struggle for people it's like here's
this here are the challenges you're
going to face and here's how to overcome
them so you're not reaching those
plateaus along the way that you can
really have
something that takes this kind of
overwhelming task of learning language
and streamlines it for you so you can
get from beginner to advanced
so a lot of books out there they show
you what to do as a beginner but there's
nothing that takes you farther and what
takes you farther that's where all a lot
of the enjoyment is because once you
remove this struggle you can then start
to be yourself in that language you can
speak as you would and you can you know
crack a joke you can you can participate
and you know hold a conversation that's
really what most people want to do they
want to they want to be able to
understand and they want to be able to
underspeak a lot of them
and so if you can't understand what
people are saying then you can't use any
of the great skills that you've learned
in order to speak to those people so
listening is very important skill so
what i want to do is take this kind of
massive task and streamline it for you
so each stage of the way you knew how to
acquire skills you knew how to put
yourself in control the language
learning situation so people to speaking
too fast for you you have 10 skills in
order to slow them down so you can you
can participate so you're not at a loss
you're not sitting there for hours on
end not understanding what people are
saying that you can actually participate
and and have ways to do that so there's
something that most people never heard
of it's called collocations and it's one
of the greatest language learning tricks
around and i'm going to explain to you
what it is in english so you can see how
often they come about and so a
collocation is a three word combination
three or more we're coming these are
words that always come together so in
english an example would be to look
forward to
something right and we fill in the
blanks so to look forward to those three
words always come together
okay so the beginning of the sentence is
structured for you
it stays the same the second half the
structure same thing you're just
changing it to suits you you suit your
needs so i could say i look forward to
speaking at sofia books tonight i look
forward to going to france i look
forward to speaking another language i
look forward to traveling abroad so you
see how we can use in different
situations so if you're not aware of
these kind of tricks these language
tricks they're just going to hold